queremos encontrar el área de esta
región que estoy sombreando en amarillo
esta región de acá la dificultad en este
problema va a ser que aunque la función
inferior siempre es x cuadrada entre 4
menos 1 pues arriba estamos en dos casos
verdad en un cachito es raíz de equis y
en el otro es 2 menos x
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
justamente dividir en estos dos casos
para poder hacer las cuentas una por una
y mira observa que 2x y raíz de x se
intersectan aquí en el punto 11 porque
si ponemos aquí x igual a 1 nos queda 1
y acá también nos queda igual a 1 de
esta forma los dos casos en los que
tenemos que dividir es cuando vamos del
0 al 1 esto nos daría una primera región
déjame marcar esta región
pues así con amarillo pero ahora más
fuerte está ya va a ser la región
amarilla vale y la segunda región la
segunda región va a ir de 1 a 2 puedes
verificar que la curva morada y la roja
se intersectan aquí en el punto 20
entonces el segundo caso lo voy a marcar
con color verde con este color verde de
por acá
entonces ahí tenemos el segundo caso muy
bien con esto en mente pues pues vamos a
hacerlo no vamos a resolver el problema
entonces cuánto nos quedaría el área
amarilla pues el área amarilla sería la
integral la integral que va de 0 a 1 de
la función que queda por arriba es raíz
de x raíz de x menos esta función de acá
la que queda por abajo - x cuadrada
entre 4 -1 de x recuerda la intuición
que está detrás de hacer esto déjame
ponerle x un poco más bonita la
intuición que está detrás de esto es que
esto nos hace rectángulos de este lado
donde el largo es de x pero que es
infinitamente flaco pero la altura es la
diferencia entre las dos funciones
entonces al hacer la integral estamos
tomando un límite de una aproximación y
por tanto estamos sumando el área de una
infinidad de rectángulos infinitamente
flacos y eso nos da el área nos da el
área
estas dos regiones muy bueno entre estas
dos curvas vale bueno esto de aquí fue
el área amarilla vamos ahora con el área
verde la de esta región de acá entonces
a esta área vamos a tener que sumarle la
integral de 1a 2b y ahora la curva que
queda por arriba es la de 2 x 2 menos x
ya eso tenemos que restar lo que está
por abajo que vuelve a hacer x cuadrado
entre 4 menos 1 b x muy bien aquí ya
tenemos planteada el área ahora nada más
tenemos que encontrar el valor de estas
integrales y para eso vamos a utilizar
el segundo teorema fundamental del
cálculo entonces esto nos queda igual
y lo primero que hay que hacer es
encontrar una una anti derivada para
esto pero primero déjame déjame
simplificar un poquito para que estos
menos no nos confundan siempre pueden y
de hacer eso entonces nos queda raíz de
x - equis cuadrado entre 4
aquí menos por menos es más 1d x más y
ahora vamos a poner la segunda nos queda
la integral de 1 a 2 de 2x es más quizás
debería apuntar este 2 con este menos
menos uno que es más 1 entonces voy a
ponerlo como 3 - x - x cuadrado entre 4
entre 4 de x ahora si a éstas les voy a
encontrar una anti derivada y vamos a
evaluar entonces pues raíz de xx a la un
medio entonces tenemos que aumentar el
exponente en 1 x a la 3 medios y dividir
entre este 3 medios que es lo mismo que
multiplicar por dos tercios va luego
menos una anti derivada para x cuadrado
es x al cubo entre 3 pero con este 4 nos
quedaría x al cubo entre 12 y una anti
derivada para uno es x mas x si
derivamos x nos queda uno muy bien esta
de acá tiene el límite superior 1 e
inferior 0
y a eso hay que sumarle una anti
derivada para ésta
con límites de 1 a 2 y vamos a ver que
queda un anti derivada para 13 es 3 x
para menos x es menos x cuadrado entre 2
si al derivar el 2 baja y se cancela con
este menos x al cubo entre 12 está ya lo
habíamos hecho por allá verdad x al cubo
entre 12 12 excelente ya tenemos las
anti derivadas ahora nada más hay que
encontrar el numerito verdad vamos a ver
cuánto nos da evaluando entonces voy a
poner un primer paréntesis aquí si le
ponemos x igual a 1 nos queda 1 a la
tres medios es un 1 todos estos son unos
entonces nada más nos quedan los
coeficientes nos queda dos tercios menos
un doceavo más uno sale ya eso hay que
restarle esta función de evaluar en cero
pero tenemos puros 000 y cero y ahora
hay que sumar lo que corresponda a este
término de acá entonces cuánto sería
éste se ve un poco más interesante 3 x
12 6
- 2 al cuadrado es 4 entre 12 2 muy bien
- ahora es 2 al cubo entre 8 2 al hub es
perdón entre 12 donde el juves 8 entre
12 812 a vos
entonces eso es evaluando en el límite
superior menos lo que quede de evaluar
en el límite inferior que es 33 menos un
medio menos un doceavo
muy bien entonces aquí está la expresión
que queremos bueno que nos va a dar el
área de la integral entonces ya nada más
queremos hacer la suma y resta de
fracciones vamos a ver si me sale vamos
a ver si me sale esto sería igual a creo
que un buen denominador sería 12 verdad
si 12 se ve como un buen denominador
común entonces dos tercios es lo mismo
que 8 12 a 28 12 ambos menos un doceavo
más 12 doceavos ok este 0 ya no lo voy a
poner y ahora vamos a pasar todo esto a
12 a 26 - dos es 44 es 48 doceavos voy a
ponerlo así 48 doceavos menos 8 12 a vos
y aquí hay que ser cuidadosos con los
signos 1336 doceavos entonces es menos
36 12 años pero aquí es menos por menos
nos queda más un medio entonces sería
más 612 ambos y finalmente menos por
menos es más
12 ok ya nada más hay que hacer la
cuenta de esto a ver cuánto nos dan a
ver en el primero nos queda 8 12 años +
12 12 años van 20 menos uno son 19 19 12
a vos y ahora con los números verdes nos
queda 48 menos 8 es 40 40 menos 36 menos
36 64
4 6 10 y 6 y 10 12 11 ok lo hice lento
para ver que no no me equivocaré
entonces nos quedan 19 12 años más 11 12
años y esto es igual a lo voy a poner ya
con color blanco esto es igual a 30 12 a
2 y si queremos simplificar podemos
dividir arriba y abajo entre 6 y nos
queda 5 medios o bien 2.5 entonces
dividiendo esta región en dos partes
determinamos que el área determinamos
que esta área que queríamos encontrar es
igual a 2.5 unidades cuadradas